If you’ve walked or driven around Washington,
DC, you’ve probably noticed these things.
Cast-iron boxes installed on street corners
all over the city, sometimes with art or a
little neighborhood history inside.
They’re clearly pretty old and not being
used for their original purpose anymore.
But what are they?
And why are they everywhere?
It turns out these cast-iron fixtures were
vital for rapid communication in cities like
Washington before the telephone was invented.
and they're really old.
Some of the original fire boxes, like this
one in DC’s Cleveland Park, even date back
to the 1860s.
You can tell the original ones by their harp
shape.
By 1890, the Gamewell Fire Alarm Telegraph
Co. had installed call box systems in 500
American cities.
This map from 1891 shows where they were installed
throughout DC.
The red dots are fire boxes, and the blue
dots are police boxes.
If you saw a fire in your own house or on
the block, you could run down to the corner
and pull the fire alarm key.
A huge network of underground cables connected
every box in the city to the central alarm
center.
There is a fire alarm box on every block of
the great city.
The number that the box would tap out matched
a location on a giant map, so the fire department
was able to pretty quickly figure out where
to send fire engines.
It could be nothing serious.
It could be a false alarm.
The police boxes worked a bit differently
than the fire boxes.
They came a little later and had an oval shape.
Like the fire boxes, the police boxes had
numbers corresponding to their location.
And police stations expected to hear from
their officers on patrol from a different
box at scheduled times.
Officers would check in and say all is well,
or they could use the box to call for backup
or receive updated orders for their patrol
area.
Using the call box system, the Metropolitan
Police Department was able to keep track of
their officers throughout the city before
the invention of two-way radio.
Technology eventually caught up, though.
More people got phones in their homes, and
the 911 system was invented in the 1970s to
link the fire and police departments.
The boxes slowly lost their purpose.
But they’re not totally obsolete just yet.
In cities like San Francisco and Boston, for
example, you can still reach the fire department
through telegraph.
In situations like earthquakes and floods
when power and cellphone services are knocked
out, these boxes are still reliably connected
to emergency services.
Here in DC, the call boxes were abandoned
in the late ’70s.
And they were just kind of … left in place
because it was cheaper and easier just to
leave them in place.
And then people just kind of forgot about
them.
They took off the boxes themselves that had
the little telephone in it.
So it just kind of looked like a little blank
piece of Victoriana street furniture that
... a lot of people had no idea what that
was.
But that changed in 2000 when members of the
nonprofit Cultural Tourism DC founded a project
called “Art on Call.”
They gave city officials a cheaper and more
creative way to deal with the iron relics:
turn them into art.
The city liked the idea, and even helped out
by stripping the lead paint and priming over
700 boxes before handing them over to the
neighborhoods.
The idea was not to just refurbish the boxes,
but for neighborhoods to come together and
decide on what they wanted their call boxes
to look like.
These call boxes have watched over the same
street corners for more than 100 years.
And even though they’re not saving lives
anymore, they continue to serve their communities
as carriers of culture and local history.